[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel bonheur de vous retrouver encore ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir si vous êtes
toujours poissard ya une boisson dégueu
une boisson délicieuse 2 3
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous avez deux jeunes filles de dos en a
une qui viendra vous faire un smack et
la celle que vous aurez choisi
celle que vous n'aurez pas choisi me
fera un smack à moi moi je dis que c'est
celle qui est à ma droite que vous
prenez ouais et piano bimaï caster your
own site
applause agency bravo alors les regarder
et moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant je continue ça c'est
magnifique on aurait dit les daft punk
leader price des sommets projet vous
êtes garde des sceaux maintenant alors
attention to the greek ruth est inquiet
dur ok ça regardez suis là je prends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais vous en mettez pas avec la
serviette à un sétois où on en est là à
la pomme déballer ouais mais ce soir je
vous dire ça m'a fait du bien c'est
bizarre ton émission tu veux tu milliers
de gens fous et témoin
[Musique]